i had a conversation a long time ago
someone during the occupy wall street
era who is a far left
anti-fog ultra woke
very intelligent
totally educated in philosophy who
completely agreed with me on everything
with one core difference
she told me it's fun to watch the world
burn
so
while there are probably
the grunts the peons the foot soldiers
of
you know critical theory who just abide
by the tenets that they've been you know
that have been espoused
it seems like there is some truth in
this in the idea of being woke
of truly understanding the nature of
humans and the philosophy of there is no
truth but power
because it seems like well they're
they're actually in a sense correct of
course there's objective truth but they
know that people will absolutely give up
any notion of truth for comforting lies
and or personal benefit and that's what
they exploit in which case i have this
conversation with an individual and we
talk about
general philosophy uh morals nihilism
solicism etc and what a person can know
and what a person can do and why we do
it and we both we ultimately come to
this conclusion that in the end we're
just kind of being hopeful that what
we're doing is the right thing because
we only know so much right what is what
is saying truism is knowing that you
know nothing and so
my my response was in which case
i'll seek to do the most good
i want people to feel better to flourish
to live long healthy lives to be happy
with their families to be protected safe
life liberty pursuit of happiness and
that means sometimes there's harsh
realities like personal responsibility
you have to work hard and it might not
be easy and she said
no i just want to watch it all get
screwed up and burn it's fun there's no
point if there's no point there's no end
and everyone just chooses what they want
to believe anyway then let's have some
fun with it and this person's extremely
active today in far-left politics yeah
writing books and and holding rallies
and and i know when i see this person
their true intent is
i want people to smash and burn because
at least life isn't boring then
well again she's acting in integrity
with what she has decided is the
the moral framework of the universe so
it's like after hegel and one of my
favorite philosophers francis schaefer
calls hagel the line of despair so it's
like at hegel philosophy changed and
people gave up the project of
understanding truth objectively and it
changed to kind of coping with this
reality that the universe is absurd and
that there is no meaning attached to our
morality there's no meaning attached to
our language there's no meaning attached
to anything we do really sad so yeah
it's very sad i mean it ends in nihilism
and despair it has to because once you
remove meaning you remove hope it's like
what's the point because like one of the
john paul start for instance like not
too long after hegel was like this is
where the this is where the trajectory
naturally goes right he his whole thing
was we can't really ever know
what's what's true what's real and if we
experience something true and real we
wouldn't even be able to communicate it
to someone else or even to ourselves
therefore the only way to like
authenticate your existence is by an
action of the will but it's still
completely disconnected from meaning and
so um francis schaeffer in this book
that i was reading recently used the
example of you're driving down the
street in the rain and you see somebody
standing with an umbrella you stop and
you pick them up and you give them a
ride and you go on and that was an act
of the will that authenticated your
existence but an equal act of the will
that would authenticate your existence
as you're driving in the rain you see
somebody with a umbrella you run them
over equally authenticating so who cares
you know it's just like and you're like
okay if that's that's where we've
arrived it's like that there's nothing
we can't attach meaning to to morality
we can't attach meaning to our words
um then yeah why not like so how do you
like say i should do these things you
know because they're kind of shoulds
right i should i want to
be good i want to help i want to you
know i have a unique moral framework
built based around um
extra negative entropy and creation and
protection
so
i wonder you know a lot of people
believe that a society can't function
without a religion obviously many people
who are christian or jewish believe that
the united states needs two main needs
to maintain these these
judeo-christian moral this this
judeo-christian world framework i agree
with them to a great extent
but you know we we've seen a society
based heavily in the moral foundations
of religion and if we went back 100
years we'd not be happy with that there
was a period where it weakened to a
point where we had a lot more liberty
than we'd ever had in the past i mean i
brought this up recently constitutional
carry of second amendment is expanding
across the country only the past 10
years in the 80s we had a second
amendment but you had less gun rights
free speech as we know it didn't
actually get solidified i think until
like 1961 because we had that ruling in
it was it brandenburg v ohio or whatever
which finally gave us true free speech
as we know it and there are still
restrictions on our speech so
it's interesting when i think about this
that
there are many people that they say red
pilled
and red build is very much the alt the
other side of being woke it means
essentially the same thing yeah but if
you look at the average woke person in
the average red pill person they
actually aren't awakened too much of
anything they're just aligned with a
political tribe as you move up higher in
the hierarchy i suppose you'll find more
and more enlightenment my personal view
of
the politics right now from the
high-profile political actors
is that on both sides you have a lot of
high-profile dumb people who don't
really know what they're talking about
don't know anything about existence
philosophy or they can't self-reflect
they probably don't meditate but then i
think there's a lot of people who
actually are
truly awakened to something so not
necessarily woke or red pill but
conscious of philosophy
i do however think those that find
themselves on the anti-woke side when
understanding philosophy
are
good
and generally speaking those on the woke
side are generally bad and the reason
for this is that
when when i started i was we had a
really great discussion about religion
several times actually we always do
these bonus segments they go for a
really long time we talk about
philosophy and religion i was talking
about my
moral foundations and and you know why i
choose to do things that i do
and it's stemmed very simply in
what life does and what life does is
organize free energy into more complex
systems the universe as we think we know
it today assuming we're correct we're
probably wrong it'll probably change in
the future is that we are looking at the
the blip just after the big bang and the
true state of the universe is the heat
death of the universe where there's just
absolutely nothing every electron evenly
spaced so far away that they can never
interact ever again we're in this period
where entropy rules the day and the
universe is slowly dying out and
spreading out and so in the meantime
there is some unique organization that
is not a singularity that creates some
kind of interesting things
free energy organizes itself into
molecules elements eventually
single-celled life forms well actually
first self-replicating proteins then
single-celled life forms and
multicellular life forms then
multicellular life forms grow to a point
where they start interacting with each
other creating ecosystems the one thing
that we can truly see life do is
organize create or i shouldn't say
create in in the physical sense they're
not making things they're organizing and
giving structure to things
the woke are the opposite they're
deconstructivists they want to take
ideas and rip them apart they want to
smash windows they want to go into
organizations and break them apart
i want to build things and make them
better get rid of the parts that are
vestigial or broken and slowly improve
upon society to the point where maybe
we'll have a star trek like future where
we're in a spaceship and we can travel
the stars and have replicators and
people are much more happy and continue
the process of
organizing the universe as it were
woke tends to be a disorganizational and
chaotic force that is a force of entropy
of course a law of the universe and the
dominant one which is a bit a [ __ ] uh
it is a bit oh not youtube's gonna claim
my sword it is a bit uh depressing
but
when i look at that conversation i had
with that woke activist who understood
much of these ideas they chose to be
chaos and destruction i chose to be
creation and order
i view creation and order as good for
very simple reasons like i mentioned we
see life do this but also
who wants to die
some people do for some reason like
their body is breaking down the
organization of their form no longer
functions and they're in pain or they're
suffering or something is wrong but most
people and almost all life one of the
core aspects of life is the desire and
the will to fight to live
so when i see a chaotic destructive
force breaking things i see that as
inherently bad because it defies the
function of what life does right not
necessarily a uh not at all i think a
christian framework any capacity but
certainly much more in alignment with
with the structure of order creation and
protection sometimes you need
destruction because too much creation
can lead to cancer too many cells
producing so you need cells to apoptosis
and destroy themselves sometimes you
need like neutral not not creation or
destruction but a balance where the cell
is just
in in not stagnation but in in synthesis
or in so there is like a neutral
aspect to
to reality i think that we're we're
missing i think it's by design too you
could you could theoretically argue that
uh the critical theorists the woke are
actually an extremely harsh version of
order
where
i recognize sometimes destruction is is
necessary if it serves the greater you
know the greater creation unfortunately
it is as we believe it now
in order for there to be negative
entropy there has to be greater entropy
created along along the way
however if you look at the woke and you
look at authoritarianism eventually they
are so rigid it's like creating a giant
tower that goes up in a straight
vertical line it collapses so in the
short term you may say if the woke had
their way they would create a rigid
power structure which is very orderly
those who take the power are in charge
and they can control systems that way
obviously the communists in in the
soviet union had structure and order but
it was so rigid and it was so straight
up that eventually you knock out one one
you know one blocking the whole thing
falls down so you need a robust
structure ultimately i view woke left
communist social etc in the long term as
a destructive path it's like watching
someone build a bridge to nowhere where
eventually just crumbles and falls to
the ground and it's destruction and
they're actively fighting against us who
are trying to build and prove and so
they're creating a system that's
susceptible to destruction because it's
brittle from its uh extension but it
does destroy it
as a result like a falling bridge will
destroy that which it lands upon
sure they also are actively stripping
organizations and structures to build
their broken system which is why
i view it more like an uh
what's the right way to put it
there there are people who are taking
resources and building something
nonsensical that will eventually destroy
the system parasitic
whatever call it what you want
i think that jordan peterson has
definitely spoken to this because he
talks about the negative ramifications
of having too much order and the
negative ramifications of having too
much chaos so when you get to the level
of authoritarianism you have too much
order but when you get to the level of
postmodernism when you can't even agree
on the definition of the word that
you're using to discuss these ideas
that is too much chaos yeah so as far as
you're concerned what fire
yeah it's fire oh how's that
it's fire it's consuming resources and
control okay okay so not parasitic it's
like burning okay but yeah so it like
these ideas are so disorganized and
unstructured this is the negative
manifest manifestation of chaos and the
negative manifestation of order in both
wrapped into this nice little package of
wokeness this critical theory and i'm
not sure what their end goal is here but
i think
hear me out about this theory let me
know what you think i think that
religion and god
worked for a long time but now it's to
the point where it doesn't make sense to
a lot of people it's hard to measure we
can't really measure it so people are
looking for a unifying theory i think
collective consciousness is real but we
don't have the tools to measure it yet
by design because we're still in the age
of combustion so these people that have
kept us on copper and oil have
inadvertently disallowed us to measure
like femtosecond vibrations of plasma
fields so we can't see our magnetic
fields interacting we don't have the
tools to measure
how do you know about that
um well if you study some research yeah
you can study like vibrations of of
surface plasmon and you can see light
interacting with plasma and like that
seems like consciousness no one's
stopping you yeah but it's not
mainstream and that's a problem because
it could have been in the 30s when tesla
was working on it but the the oil
companies and the copper they wanted to
suppress that this is that you're
blaming someone else for what you should
be doing i think the the
the unexpected result is this uprising
of a new religion because we've
suppressed what is actually real
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you